does it feel good to be here glammed up
and beautiful and not dressed as a cat
lady I'll take either one really it's
all it's all drag to me and I love it
all yeah I mean it's so ridiculous to be
here in the best possible way it's like
you get to see all these people that you
admire so much and you're all kind of
feeling the same thing like we're all
movie fans so it's it's just as exciting
like I'm a big movie watcher so I just
kind of keep looking around I want to
know what kind of snacks you brought us
all tonight that's right I was gonna
look under food in the cave now I think
I just brought liquid snacks
refreshments refreshments
you took a great picture in the car and
then you also what is this explain that
that was my homage to Barbra Streisand
the one the only because she had I would
say Richard is obsessed and loves her so
much beyond access how much are we all
and then he said had she seen the movie
I'm like I'm not gonna call Barbara and
ask her if she's seen her own movie like
it's just not the call I made and then
she put out and Twitter's of comments
saying I did email you just blew me off
you blew off Barbara my email I haven't
checked you did after that right yes and
I was like I'm the worst I'm terrible
what does she say she's just laughing
but I was like I don't I did tell her
I'm like I really don't check it and
she'd just not have one no I mean I'm
being nosy what did she say in the email
she just said that she loved him moving
and was really nice about it but I just
I went radio silent I didn't tell you
what I didn't see it I would never will
I've never danced and that happened one
time
is phenomenal the movies great
congratulations mr. lost and this is
beautiful who in his body
Brandon Maxwell I just loved it it felt
so strong and it felt right Aaron all
right any problems navigating the Cape
Town no not yet I feel like it's a
little it's just superhero enough that
I'm like people are it's creating a
radius my life
[Music]